my first job in the morning is to make
coffee i'm not a big coffee drinker but
my wife is
and then we sit there and i'll show you
that we sit there and we look at our
ipads my wife looks at her
tennis or her
piano or golf
and i
do a little bit of reviewing of
flashcards or reading so i'll show you
that later on but at least this is the
start of my day i've finished breakfast
and cleared the table
haven't yet done the breakfast dishes
but i've got a few things to clean up so
i'll do that while listening
but i'm sitting here
uh enjoying my ipad
and basically right now you'll see here
that i have a number of lessons here
you know
varying it from
um sort of casual conversation uh
and more serious articles
from the voice of russia which
um
you know some of the stuff is quite
interesting
this particular item you can see it
highlighted in blue has to do with
the oil industry and pipelines between
russia and china but before i go through
the text again and bear in mind i've
already gone through the text once on my
computer creating links i like to go
through
the
flash cards
and the way i do flash cards is i put
everything up front like i'm not going
to scratch my brain here i put the the
word the translation and the captured
phrase all up front
and if i want i can listen to it
and listening to it a few times helps
kind of soak it in because to me flash
carding is all about exposure it's not
about trying to spend
all kinds of time racking my brain for
stuff that i can't remember
uh and so then i just move it along
and we go to the next flash card
and if i want i listen to that
and so i go through that and there's
quite a bunch like i've got 98 flash
cards to go through but i'll go through
them quite quickly
and then when i finish that then i will
go here and
open up the lesson
and then i'll read through the lesson
and inevitably there are words that
you know that i don't uh remember so
i'll have to tap on them to see what
they are
if i in fact remember that one i might
move it up in status
towards known and of course the thing
about reading and listening is that you
always have the impression that it's
always difficult always the same places
you don't understand when reading and
listening but i know from experience
that over time you get better and all of
a sudden
it starts to the brain gets used to the
patterns of this language
so just a
brief thing on how i use the ipad and
i'll probably spend a good hour or two
today with the ipad
so there you have it some snippets of my
study day i should tell you a secret
i'm hoping to put in two three or more
hours a day into learning my korean
i can afford to do that now because i'm
sort of semi-retired
i've worked for more than 45 years
uh but when i was learning russian and
to a large extent czech and
some of the earlier languages literally
i all the time i had was driving to work
driving home
doing the dishes exercising so it was
like 70 listening so i expect that in
three months of korean i'm hoping with
that amount of time that i'm going to
make significant progress but i can tell
you when i was learning russian and i
only had an hour or so a day mostly
listening
three months would go by and i wasn't
aware of any progress i mean it took me
five years to reach
well i spent a good five years at it but
yeah my comprehension was starting to
come after a few years but it took a
long time
and nothing wrong with that
i feel tremendously happy that i can
understand russian movies i can read the
newspaper i can listen to audiobooks i
can communicate with mistakes there's
always someone at youtube who comes on
and tells me that my russian's no good
or my spanish is no good which is fine
uh it works if i had only one language
to concentrate on i would really you
know take it to that extra level but it
serves its purpose it's it's enabling me
to communicate with another culture in
another language so the point i wanted
to make is i have a lot of time to spend
so i'm doing a lot of stuff if i have
dedicated time i'm reading i'm linking
uh for the longest time i only had that
passive listening time or you know 70 80
percent
so however much time you have
uh
do it and stay with it
and the more time you put in the more
obvious will be the results and if you
haven't got that much time it may seem
that you're not getting anywhere but you
have to stay with it because when you
get to that level when you get those
eureka moments
it's tremendously satisfying i think we
have a tendency to
expect too much short-term gain
and then we are sort of we underestimate
how much we really improve in the long
term
so that's the end of my day 9.